alors où les européens se préparent à se
réunir à bruxelles les vingt-sept vont
évidemment par les sanctions ce soir et
déjà la directrice du fmi du fonds
monétaire international réagir il y à
quelques instants à l'alerter sur
l'important risque économique pour la
région et le monde tout entier justement
focus sur les conséquences économiques
l'économie c'est évidemment le nerf de
la guerre avec vous leur manne un bon
jour lors de l'union européenne et les
etats unis annoncent des sanctions un
déjà et économiques exceptionnelles
qu'elles sont elles et qu'elles peuvent
en être les a fait on a beaucoup dit ces
derniers jours que ça ne fonctionnait
pas ça fonctionnait pas ou alors ça
fonctionne mais de manière préventive
plutôt en faveur de la russie en fait
les occidentaux tape du poing sur la
table adoptent des mesures
exceptionnelles mais il l'avait déjà
fait en 2014 au moment de l'annexion de
la crimée et ça a servi de l'uci de
leçons finalement à la russie la russie
qui a donc développé des nouvelles
stratégies par exemple a décidé de
produire davantage sur son territoire
pour moins dépendre des importations de
cette manière par exemple elle est
devenue le premier exportateur mondial
de blé entre 2014 et aujourd'hui elle
avait donc bien retenu la leçon au point
que le blé aujourd'hui rapporte
davantage que les ventes d'armes
concernant le dollar les états unis
veulent fermer le robinet des dollars
sauf que la russie la russie avait
anticipé en 2013 cent pour cent de ses
ventes d'hydrocarbures se faisait en
dollars aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus que
10 % qui s'échangent en billets verts là
aussi elle a retenu la leçon et elle est
aussi échanger une partie de ses
réserves en dollars contre de l'or et
des one parce que elle se tourne vers de
nouveaux partenaires commerciaux
notamment la chine on va en reparler
dans un instant et puis l'exclusion du
sweet system swift bancaire qui permet
de faire des échanges notamment en gros
en résumé comme vous fait un virement ça
passe par ce système est bien là aussi
elle avait développé son propre système
donc finalement fait avoir des
conséquences à va avoir des conséquences
mais peut-être davantage pour les
occidentaux qui n'ont pas anticipé que
la russie s'était beaucoup préparé la
russie qui avait effectivement anticipé
en ce qui est en train d'arriver et qui
aussi diversifier son portefeuille de
clients qui se tournent depuis plusieurs
années vers la chine fort voilà
plusieurs nations émergentes vers
laquelle elle s'est tournée le brésil
l'inde et puis la chine qui est devenue
son premier partenaire commercial
depuis 12 ans pour vous donner une idée
des proportions de renforcement de ce
partenariat
en 2020 les importations chinoises de
gaz russe ont augmenté de
75% c'est énorme évidemment 31 %
d'augmentation qu en ce qui concerne le
pétrole après l'annexion de l'écrit mais
un gazoduc a également été développée
entre les deux pays ainsi qu'un axe
autoroutier pour faciliter les échanges
avec un pont qui est en cours de
développement pour les échanges de
marchandises il faut dire que c'est
relativement simple puisque les deux
pays partagent 4000 km de frontière
commune c'était assez logique finalement
on le sentait depuis un moment déjà la
montée des tensions pousser le pétrole à
la roue salle est déjà très fort depuis
la déclaration de la lumière poutine il
a franchi un nouveau seuil symbolique
celui des 100 $ 100 $ le baril ça fait
mal ça fait mal c'est très longtemps
qu'on n'avait pas vu ce ce seuil franchi
ce monde encore une fois à 2014 là
encore on remonte dans le temps au
moment de la crimée entre-temps rappelez
vous il ya quand même eu la pandémie les
avions cloués au sol les gens cloué chez
eux une baisse de la demande
considérable le dollar était passé quand
même à 0 1 ça coûtait plus cher de le
garder en stock chez soi que de le
brader vraiment pas cher donc c'est un
bond considérable en espace de deux ans
le brent de la mer du nord qu'est la
référence en europe a franchi les 100
dollars ce matin il évolue autour de 105
dollars vers 15h30 gmt le wti américain
lui lui emboîter le pas c'est aussi
danser dans ces proportions là les
tensions actuelles font exploser prix du
baril à cause de cette offre du but de
cette loi de l'offre et de la demande
rappelons que la russie c'est quand même
le troisième producteur mondial de pau
col de pétrole deuxième exportateur
mondial voyez le brésil est à + 7 58
d'augmentation un peu moins pour pour le
wti américain mais c'est quand même
considérable les investisseurs craignent
déjà des provinciales des problèmes
d'approvisionnement sur un marché qui
était déjà tendue voilà c'est aussi
comme le gaz c'est voilà c'est aussi le
cas sur un autre secteur là les
inquiétudes elles sont formulées déjà
depuis de longues semaines de l'eau moi
même mais là pour le coup ça se
concrétise vraiment ça se concrétise
notamment parce que l'europe dépend
énormément du gaz russe qui lui fournit
40% de ses stocks sur le marché
néerlandais
gaza explose il a plus de 50 %
d'augmentation à l'heure où l'on parle
sur le marché néerlandais où il est coté
la russie vous savez alimente l'europe
de l'ouest par plusieurs gazoducs
notamment nord trendel la certification
de l'opérateur a été bloqué par
l'allemagne mais le gazoduc existe déjà
depuis septembre 2021 est parallèle à
north stream 1 qui passe lui aussi par
la baltique c'est bien pratique pour la
russie ça lui évite de payer de ford
roide on va dire de péage à l'ukraine
qui a elle aussi un gazoduc brotherhood
que l'air que la russie utilisé jusqu'à
présent mais quelle qu'elle réduit au
maximum parce qu'elle n'a pas envie de
donner beaucoup d'argent au régime
ukrainien la russie s'en désengage au
fur et à mesure et l'union européenne va
donc devoir trouver de nouveaux
fournisseurs elle sentait déjà le vent
tournait depuis un moment alors les
états unis l'avons trouvé un marché
supplémentaire pour leur gaz de schiste
c'est tout bénef pour eux si on peut
dire côté européen il ya la norvège et
les pays bas qui pourrait fournir sauf
qu'ils sont déjà au maximum de leurs
capacités de production salle est
difficile de leur demander davantage
reste le qatar qui est un gros
producteur de petr de gaspard dont
également mais qui a déjà des contrats
avec des clients qui ne pourra
finalement détournée que 10 à 15% de sa
production vers l'europe ça va donc être
tendue dans les mois à venir on y pense
mais c'est un autre effet secondaire là
aussi très concret c'est le prix des
denrées alimentaires il s'envole lui
aussi alors des roseraies et alimentaire
puisque vous le disais tout à l'heure
avec rennes c'est le grenier à blé de
l'europe la russie aussi produit
énormément notamment depuis 2014 moscou
qui est le premier exportateur de blé au
monde avec 20 % des échanges
internationaux 10% pour l'ukraine à
elles deux la russie et l'ukraine
détiennent quand même un tiers du marché
mondial pour les pays qui en dépendent
au tour de l'union européenne et on voit
le prix de la tonne de blé qui s'est
envolé à plus de 9% d'augmentation plus
si 57 2 pour le maïs ce sont des records
qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis plusieurs
mois pour la plus craints et faut savoir
quels produits 12% du blé mondial 16 %
du maïs toute la planète et bien sûr
quand on est dans un pays en conflit pas
c'est difficile d'aller cultiver puis
ensuite d'aller exporter il va falloir
donc se serrer la ceinture le prix des
pâtes de la farine notamment augmente
déjà ça va nous rappeler des souvenirs
quelles vont être les effets concrets
pour
l'économie ça c'est un point de levier
important qu'on va évidemment scruté de
très près et que les russes vont voir se
concrétiser ça ça peut être un élément
important dans leur vision de la
situation et dans leur soutien ou non à
vladimir poutine c'est en tout cas ce
qu'espèrent les occidentaux avec ces
mesures ces sanctions parce que dans un
premier temps les sanctions visent les
oligarques les proches du pouvoir
concrètement la population ça lui fait
pas vraiment chaud ou froid là c'est un
peu l'effet tranchant le double effet
tranchant que qu'attendent les
occidentaux mais en réalité ça risque
d'avoir des effets limités d'abord parce
que il ya aussi des effets pour les
fournisseurs les pays qui sont en
contact avec la russie les occidentaux
donc les entreprises européennes
américaines les entreprises françaises
représentent quand même 160 mille
employés privés en russie ça risque
quand même d'être compliqué pour ce qui
concerne la russie c'est un peu
difficile d'anticiper la mesure que vont
avoir c est fait ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que c'est un une sorte de géant
aux pieds d'argile la russie certains
pays chez contexte avec une importante
population mais son pib ne représente
que 60 % du pib français et ses
hydrocarbures reprendre représente 50 %
de son budget or en fermant le robinet
la russie va se priver de revenus très
importante c'est embêtant je vous
propose d'écouter aussi fatih birol le
directeur de l'agencé internationale
n'ont pas l'écouter parce qu'on n'a pas
le temps on n'a pas le temps à donald
agit des déchets d'intérêt juste un mot
en nous on a les chiffres c'est
important les marchés les mariages y
avait des mouvements balewa endroit
rivoire wistron catastrophé par la
situation les le dow jones et tous les
marchés américains sont en rouge -2 10
pour le dow jones -1 62 pour le sm caen
- 46 pour le nasdaq côté européen
c'était beaucoup plus marqué puisque
forcément c'est plus près on est on
frôle les 5 % de chute sur les marchés
européens wall a du rouge partout y
compris merci beaucoup